I think we're going to have to realize  that some people's object level desires  and made a level desires may  fundamentally conflict with each other  if they're given more of the truth and  people should not attach too much of a  terminal value to being better than  other people or being superior to other  people and and for those who fail  structure lives and those metrics I  think it's that better to figure out how  they can still achieve other needs  without having to be better than others  so I will not everyone if necessarily  dishonestly it that was openness to same  extent that I do  I seen you still possible for the other  attributes like laws were meaning that  doesn't if they'll have true some  hierarchies definitely  you